If there was gonna be a one shot like
just you guys, what would you do in if
you could pick like 15 minute like a
one-shot kind of scene you guys are a
little adventure what would you get up to?
Hmm... I'd like to see her teach Bucky
how to dance. Yes I was just thinking
that! You do you know what the Milly rock
is? No okay so it's a dance that was
created a little while ago and this
song's called Milly Rock and you kind of
have to just it's like you're like
whooping flies right so on set I was
teaching him how to do the Milly Rock
with one arm. With one arm!
And it's the arm that is... That was later yeah, when the arm came back yeah right when
you got your... Do they see that in the trailer? Yeah they know I had the arm. Great. It's on the poster...Secrecy! Good. No but with the arm yes yes the
arm he was Milly Rocking so I think we
would have a dance competition we will
learn you know learn a few things you
know we ended in the lake so it would
take like boat rides and stuff we'd go
on the boat. Yeah just like yeah yes a
little lake trip yeah nice. That sounds
amazing.
She would have Bucky like redo the
Titanic 'I'm the king of the world'...
She'd be behind she'd be the Jack and you'd be the Rose...Exactly but he'd have only one arm. You
guys have some of the best hair I would
say in the MCU arguably. Thank you. What's been your best kind of hair look? What do you think?
I mean you've been here for a
while. I feel like we've really
gotten it pretty well in this film I
mean you know given the trajectories of
Bucky's hair, yeah it's been pretty good.
I remember when I remember when we did
our scene and Ryan was like and I was
like... I was just thinking about that! And Ryan was like, why don't we put it in a bun? And I was like, like a man bun? And he was like no,
is there a word for when there's when it's
down but then there's like half up? Half up, half down.
And then you give you were thinking, you were contemplating, 'how's he gonna do this with one hand?'
Yeah yeah I was like how's he gonna do that with one hand? And he was like 'the kids did it...'
But you are The Winter Soldier as well I feel like he could handle a bun...
So obviously you guys are in and out of
makeup all the time um what's been like
for both of you what's the best kind of
beauty hack to keep yourself looking
glowing and fresh after the scene ends or after the end of the shoot? Erm, exfoliating
Erm, Black Panther world taught me about
the importance of exfoliating I I would
go home and get some some really nice
scrubs and just scrub out all of the dirt
all of the, maybe the dust that's been you
know, had a big day of fighting scenes
and plus on top of that they put makeup over the dust. She always looks beautiful. She's being very modest.
Aww! I taught him how to be a gentleman whist in Wakanda. Yourself? Do you have a specific...
I'll just tell you go out there and get
sleep obviously I'm not a good
representative of that so don't look at me
for that, but sleep is the way to go.
You gotta get sleep. Sleep, water and
exfoliation. Yes
hydration. These sound like absolutely
amazing bits of advice. And fruits. Yeah. And what would
you, so Tom Holland said recently he's got
into trouble a bit and he's not like he
wasn't allowed to go wasn't allowed to
read the full script, was that the same
for you guys like when you were doing it
were you allowed to it were you like in
you know you didn't know what happened
or? How did that work? Were you given your scenes? Or were you allowed the whole script? I was just only
given my the scenes that I was in I
didn't read, I've never read the
whole script so. And you still haven't
seen it, I assume? It's nice to see that others
have oh isn't it? Hmm do you think that's because you're less trustworthy and others are
more trustworthy? Have you given away spoilers before? Woah woah woah woah...
Hannah, you started off pretty good here... I mean, it's a lot of projecting, that's all I've got to say about that...
I'm sorry!
My apologies my apologies. It was just
that it was not given it to us. It was not. Nobody
received the script. They're like you're in a
freezer anyway right now yeah yeah yeah
And I suppose like even before like do
you have any idea what the name of
Avengers 4 is? We can guess
though... See I've had a few guesses as well.
What do you say? So I was like, okay Avengers Disassembled... haha! Maybe.
Avengers what is it, there's like - Avenge Us...Avenge Us! Oh I love it. But that wasn't me that was
actually some from Twitter so I have to give them credit -
Avenges Us -  or like I feel like
we haven't had a lot of Hawkeye and I
feel like plot twist Avengers Hawkeye
Reborn. Or it'll be something very
obscure like the 37th stone. No there's too many stones...
And you're like what is that? Or Avengers Thanos, I'm Back. But wait. I'm baaack! I'm back like I never left... the whole thing. Still here. I ain't going nowhere.
Well thank you so much, I'm very excited for this movie and obviously Avengers Thanos, I'm back, never left...Thank you that was fun.